[Music]
[Music]
I breath I get big fancy headphones we
don't have headphones are you gonna wear
headphones these got some fence
microphones I told myself when I start
monetizing this thing then I'll be able
to up my game to headphones seen it
that's what I know I made it when
headphones are in play do most
interviews you do have headphones no I
just thought I was on a picture people
were like digging here but I know tone
was drinking mimosas I saw that yeah
that was him so that was his he's great
though yeah his parents live down the
street from me oh really
yeah we didn't know that why would we
know that but like he came in town one
time and I never car he's like I want to
come hang out and have a car a job
because you know I'm a lady mmm he's
like come on I could pick you up that's
all right he give my address
he's like why the hell are you a mile
and a half away at our boy your parents
house so yeah like a mile and a half if
I'm oh yeah come on and you both won
stand up NBC in because like it he did
like if you listen to his interview on
hybrid podcast oh well he he did like he
did like uptown and like bombed he did
something with a black top improv I am
around and he said he said he got booed
there and um yeah the first time I went
uptown big candy tried to call me into
him black pop and I didn't bomb but I
didn't do great and I'd only doing
stand-up like less than a year oh wow
and be Kenny try to get me to do it the
other guys in black topper like now
you're good background was there and I
did all right and there's like one other
time I got a bit of town and I had a
perfectly fine set mm-hmm
and that [ __ ] [ __ ] DJ can't
imagine like I started playing the music
that plays when people bomb and the host
guy rappin was I never
I was like what are you doing even the
host was like she didn't why are you
playing this music for her and he goes I
mean I know she didn't bomb but I like
it that much and he's like that's not
the [ __ ] point is that my mother's in
the bottom just going like this I sit
down and she's like I'm putting a hit
out on that limb because we like I've
been up down a bunch of times I've never
seen him yeah yeah because you can't see
him he's an ant right yeah so the DJ
booths bigger than he is definitely he
doesn't even know who's on [ __ ] stage
and then the girl is broken went up
before me and all she talks about how
she just graduated from college
and everyone was like applauding and
[ __ ] you know sing a [ __ ] joke but
she's started by saying that she just
graduated from college so nobody wanted
to boo her stand up yeah and I'm in the
back like boo this [ __ ] this is not a
[ __ ] accomplishment
so she can do homework are we recording
yet we're we are recording please I
should say D say tu nombre export vibora
hey I am Dulce Sloane I do the stand-ups
in acting and improv and sketch me stuff
Dulce Sloane Oh
bienvenidos a break boo boo driver named
Julio and her labia at night and there's
a little [ __ ] gifts and and he's
like oh he do this with the he can run
on the windows cue like turn the air
conditioning how are you guys how much
shut the [ __ ] up
this is 2:00 in the morning be quiet and
this [ __ ] has a list of demands mm-hmm
and he's like I really like this song he
turn it up and then I just start talking
to you we're driver in Spanish so of
course he turned the radio down oh yeah
you could talk to me the course of
conversations like your boys probably
upset that you turn the radio down or
cracking the [ __ ] up oh yeah you have
absolutely no idea what's going on it's
a nice little weapon like it is I'm not
fluent but I know enough to get like
discounts yeah like I don't know
in an uncomfortable conversation so you
married you got a boyfriend I just
wanted more fries yeah gustas corona no
you gotta marry you got a boyfriend you
got kids more fries what's going through
this with you sir a sweetness porfavor
yeah got the war husbands I got 72 kids
and I have no interest in this
conversation [ __ ] outta my face thank
you so much Ashley thank you for doing
this well it's cool people in here I was
like oh man I hope he asked me and he
did geez how'd you get hot water this is
that was prepared huh yeah I when you
said you were in McDonough I was like
okay let me yeah no you're you're not
late compared to some people who are
like yeah yeah today and then when I do
some phone interviews one time somebody
gave me the wrong phone number what yeah
um another time they just didn't answer
and then like sent me a Facebook message
oh sorry about that and then I had to do
it like the next week or something you
know and like 30 minutes isn't bad
compared to days for a we yeah yeah yeah
I'm like so no you're great I've been
doing this I've learned you know
scheduling is a very flexible word yes
so I appreciate you just doing in the
same day and I said I was coming and
you're not going all Hollywood yet
because you just won NBC stand-up so
it's or stand-up for NBC I guess it's
NBC's Jennifer diversity yeah it's it's
a stand-up NBC now mm-hmm
apparently they took off the diversity I
don't know what white kids suit because
there's like in like the showcase
there's eight people and dealing like
legit why dude also have like a glass
eye so there are no fully functioning
ever know
Abell like fully unjust full white dudes
mm-hmm there which nothing just I'm just
a white man that guy wasn't there
well your neighbor he's from Atlanta
technically he's the game but I guess he
would be the consider the gay guy yeah
he's gay and he's half Latino but it's
good to see it land out there
representing and of course we've had
others like Lavar Walker and tone Bell
of course you know connected to the NBC
stand-up brand I gotta ask you alright
did it
rob Hayes - uh I can't believe I forgot
rob Hayes of course all have been on hot
breath is Oh cuz I know I had to mix Rob
hey I got a [ __ ] phone call why'd you
say me I didn't want to say you me and
robber friend shout out to rob Hayes he
was actually the first hot breath Asotin
he was the inaugural episode of hot
breath so makes perfect sense shouts out
to him I want to ask you right off the
bat with NBC stand up and you winning
did you rock the bra out yeah of course
you rocked it out on the final of course
and no one knew um because I'd like
every time I would I wear that to a show
I am if it's not like if it's here
everybody knows but like when I gonna
did Montreal and when I did this I uh I
wear camels I got where shrug so I'm
completely wrapped up and they even with
in with it being winter I have like a
rap over it so no one knows what I'm
wearing until I get right both right
when they're announcing mine when
they're introducing me mm-hmm that's
when I take everything off then I go up
stage so no one knew what I had oh my
god except for Christina who was like
also in that like who was also
showcasing Christina galliston like Aish
I was like girl I said girl come here
did you like oh yeah no one no one knew
it and I guess you got to link up with
tone Bell why you were there was that
your first time meeting him or you guys
knew each other before no I omit him
back in like I think was 2011 or 2012 he
um he came and did relapse right um it
was like he's amazing I love him um so
yeah he came into relapse and then we've
just kind of been cool since then just
cuz Jake
his parents look so close to me this how
he comes back in town he's at his
parents house so and like he was on he
hosted the final showcase in LA so he
like I was able to talk to him like
beforehand I'm like I was like I'm
nervous he's like shut up oh it doesn't
[ __ ] he just calm down do your [ __ ]
he's a being here is already a big deal
yeah [ __ ] roll with it so what I did
since he won you know he's been on
multiple BBC shows I mean how is your
life changed in just cuz you won like
within the month I guess yeah cuz what
happened like there they usually when we
they told us that cuz the thing is we
have a rehearsal on Monday and then the
showcases on Tuesday but like janus from
NBC who's awesome um we sit down with
her and some other people from the
network who are in the talent infusion
program and I'm like okay wanna see us
at and they give you notes on your set
so they give you so they do the
rehearsal so you can have notes on your
set and so your set is locked in so they
know what you're going to say basically
and they know you time it cuz we only
have like six seven minutes okay so um
yeah they look me Dave you rehearse at
first and then the show was the next
night so we did the rehearsal and
there's no one else at the rehearsal
other than the people who were
showcasing and then for people from NBC
and we were at the Hollywood improv on
Melrose so we were in this 200 seat room
and there's like two o'clock in the
afternoon and they're like alright
everybody do you set what a gentleman
fee supportive don't we dig yeah and so
you just the thing you listen everybody
set but yeah it's um yeah tone hosted
and you won I won
but they told us that Monday that the
results don't come out till January oh
so you're not supposed to find out who
wins until January and I got a phone
call the next day
and then they were like we needed
something for the press release for
putting it out next week so it usually
comes out in January but they were so
jazzed about Dulce Sloane well they were
like cuz like I was it I was that a the
city walking Universal getting food in a
my manager called me and he was like
what you doing I'm like getting food
look you might want to sit down but I
didn't expect him to be telling me that
because it doesn't go up to January and
I'm auditioning for different things
like I did like two auditions like I'd
done two auditions while I was there or
audition already while I was there and I
was like oh maybe something I did tape
four and he was like you won and I was
like I won what he's like NBC and I was
like [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah January he's like well they figured
out who the winner was so you need to
give a statement for the press release
oh so I did that and it's a twelvemonth
talent deal and you know it's
auditioning with them and you know
working with them just seeing everything
that I can do you know just feel like
hey tone what's this mean so you know
maybe he can explain all of it to me cuz
people like you won what I don't think I
know all of it good not quite sure I
fully understand let me look at what
contract figure it all out so they did a
press release the following Thursday and
I was coming back from Nashville and I
was I cuz for you know don't know Aetna
Nashville is four hours from Atlanta so
I had just gotten into Georgia I was
probably like 15 miles into the state
and my tire blew mmm tire split down the
side tire blew and now I'm on the side
of the road I'm hungry I have to pee and
it's a special time of young girl's life
so I was very upset and I'm sitting on
the side of the road freaking out like
[ __ ] what am I gonna do what am I gonna
do what am I gonna do and I have to pee
and I started the first text I got was
from bikini and he was like oh
congratulations I was like
huh he's like congratulations I saw it
on Twitter and it's all good on Twitter
cuz deadline is the one that put it out
and I go on Twitter and I look at the
timestamp when the press release hit is
when my tire blew two minutes of each
other oh my god like your life is
changing your life is exactly the same
so my call mama and then like and then
Reggie called me and he was like it's
out its out Presley stuff it's out and I
was like yeah it's great it's a gift so
that means up where you were I was like
sitting on the side of the road with a
flat tire and then he just proceeds to
start laughing Oh everywhere everybody
was like Andrew mark will called me Oh
maybe like girl what are you doing
regulations like this I pee inside the
room change my clothes like I change his
[ __ ] tire and all the lug nuts loosen
and then some white dad stopped and I
know he's a white dad because he was
white into some of the car and he was
like go stand over there and I'm like
okay and he changed my tire look you
split and then I went to Walmart but
he's you know you're in a country ass
place when there's an Auto Center after
your local Walmart and you're like so
what happened is in my tire blew by
tonight and I'm joking around with him I
said yeah you know what else happened
today and then I showed them the press
release and they were like this that's
funny I was like why the [ __ ] does
everybody think this is hilarious
because it is hilarious oh my god that's
such a beautiful irony because you've
you've built so much momentum up to that
point not only did you win NBC but
throughout the year you came in second
laughing skull festival and you got new
faces at Just for Laughs so it's only
fair near the end of the year for this
to just well this is the special timing
here with cars actually but the
fucked-up part was that bought that tire
like three weeks before that I just got
the [ __ ] tire and I was like you
mother because the other one was messed
up and I was like maybe I just gotta
stop buying used tires their own was
like stop buying retreads I'm like
listen don't [ __ ] retread means okay I
don't you talking about
the tire was perfectly fine when I drove
so yeah that was my I called my mom and
she's like girl
means you blowing up I'm like that's
what you think this means that's what
cars last for ah well let's hope you
mommy you're gonna be on the road a lot
don't you get some college tour deal
with this as well um there is a college
tour that you get but I was already
doing already doing college shows with
NACA
right with NASA so I applied to five
knackers and I got in a three of them
and so I went to beautiful exotic places
like Tulsa Oklahoma Buffalo New York
angry in Lansing Michigan which to get
two grand lasting you have to take a sip
separate [ __ ] plane from Chicago to
MIT to brands lands do the program but
you're [ __ ] Grand Rapids and all the
plane ride consists of is flying over
one of the Great Lakes it's a total [ __ ]
plane right like how big is this [ __ ]
Lake for this plane want to take an hour
but then you realize you're in a plane
it only had like there was probably like
20 rows of seats but one row but one
aisle down the side up there was only
one seat for up oh yeah as long as I
know commuter planes or a thing don't
live that way but tiny [ __ ] plane so
yeah and I booked like all these college
shows and then I got to go out to LA for
pilot season so it's gonna be a lot of
back and forth
cuz I'll show that booked or on the East
Coast mm-hmm so it's gonna be a lot of
bouncing back and forth well this is
this is what you've been working for
them yeah cuz like I got to quit my day
job which time here right now um I got
to quit my day job like a month ago was
that after just for laughs you quit her
I I quit because I think I was only
supposed to get muzzles give five days
off a year okay and my boss let me take
13 because of festivals and you know
having to go to LA and September yeah
and she was like she well the deal is I
gotta get her a Mercedes is the [ __ ]
deal Wow um but she was really
supportive of me she really believed
in me and she was always very helpful to
me so Gabi gravely know my crazy
Romanian she's remaining she's hilarious
though was this the call center job I
was breaking at a stucco Supply Company
okay with way too much [ __ ]
responsibilities way too much way too
much you want me me who does not care
listen it was an amazing job because
that job had the money to do what I
needed to do he was a salary job
stepping stone right so without that job
of when they've been able to be able to
afford to go to Napa or when I went out
of town to do stuff I would have been
able to do it but I was like I got its
got the NBC thing while she was on
vacation in Romania and I was like okay
I'm gonna have to leave at the end of
the month because it's like I'll act
like my front last day is this day
because the first week of December I
gotta go to LA anyway alright
and the my college is you hit me up like
hey we had a last-minute thing for you
to do in Texas and I was like like so
you're telling me I can make my whole
income for the month in an hour
oh wait hey Gaby oh listen I am NOT
gonna be able to do it labels like
because we weren't sure was going back
and forth so I found out like on
Wednesday and she was like you just
gotta send me an email and my last day
was Monday how long were you at that job
I got that job February of 2014
okay so almost two years which is crazy
that I was there that long but um yeah I
worked at home and it was like it wasn't
a strike like it wasn't stressful all
the time because there was a lot of
times we weren't doing [ __ ] and we just
made crafts in that time you also worked
on the TV show resurrection yeah what
was your experience with that and how
that come into play resurrection was I
got fired sorry
released from a temp assignment okay um
I got released Monday this was 2013 I
get released from a temporary assignment
so I got that job from I had done a play
for nine months back in like 2009 it was
a fox I play called Sunday afternoon at
Loehmann's and one of the guys that was
in the show was helping with the casting
for Resurrection for the first season so
he hit me up and was like hey what you
doing I'm like being unemployed what you
doing and like literally like I got
released on Tuesday the following
Tuesday I was on set mmm so one of the
girls text was like girl you all right
how you doing I'm like yeah I'm on the
set of a TV show I'm fine I'm [ __ ]
good and then a week later I mean not a
week later a month later I did up my
first Rickles pics yeah with Rob Riggle
from Fox NFL Sunday and I got that
through Sarah Tiana
Rob Riggle was here shooting Dumb and
Dumber to and they contacted her like
look going back to Atlanta and you know
like black female comics we can use and
she's like oh I know somebody and she
gave them my name and then I sent them
my leak to rooftop and they're like yeah
and so they hit me up on Tuesday Friday
I was on set and then they asked me to
come back to following week to do
something else yeah and these acting
gigs are not by accident a lot of people
don't know I mean you've been an actor
your entire life I've been acting I was
a kid I've been sag eligible since like
2007
um but yeah I've been acting my whole
life I'm done like commercials that's
the first time ever once that land was
for was to shoot a commercial Oh for
what for African pride uh-huh so when my
hair was still straight but I did a
cover I did want to hear that
infomercial hear of her African pride
and they paid me a thousand dollars to
cut and relax and color my hair
and then they proceeded to put all of
the weave in it
mm-hmm so any black women listening
because I was in the box if they came up
with this new perm with these herbs and
[ __ ] in it uh-huh and I was on the
coupon in the box African pride African
pride but this was like like in 2009 but
um yeah and then that job got bought by
some strong company because working at
an insurance company and they got bought
and they started to downsize me and one
of my friends were the first ones to get
let go
cuz we didn't have any kids we didn't
have any family and we're like you know
last hired first fired mm-hmm so uh they
let us go and then I didn't do [ __ ]
hung out this is before I this is before
I started doing this was the year I
started doing stand-up so just sitting
around the theater degree just like I
don't know what to do well because I got
because of me not working I got booked I
booked the play oh cool and then I
started doing stand-up so at that time I
was just doing stand-up and then I was
just doing this play cuz it was that the
Ansley Park Playhouse so we gonna you
know money's um so yeah I was doing this
play and I was students playing and I
was working I was working in a plane I
started stand-up Kyle started stand-up
May of 2009 and how did you land in
Georgia because I think you've lived
like kind of all around the country
haven't you yeah my I mean me and my mom
won in Miami my father my brother born
in Oklahoma um and my parents got
divorced and we moved to Colorado and
then we moved to Georgia but all of
those moves happened before I started
kindergarten oh wow
so and then I went to like we lived in
College Park went to school my mother's
like [ __ ] this and then I was pulling
each point for a couple of months I'm
like [ __ ] so we lived in austell mm-hmm
but um I went to school in st. Springs
and then my brother went to daycare cuz
I'm to you I was 2 years I had my
brother in school so we would get up in
the morning my mother would drop my
brother off downtown for daycare I would
go to elementary school like first grade
in Sandy Springs and then she would go
to work in Norcross Wow this was every
morning my mother dish my mother drove a
Volkswagen Fox into the ground and then
we would like visit my grandma on the
weekends in Miami so we would get off a
school on Friday
my mother would drive a like 11 hours to
Miami just cuz you wanted to see your
mom then and then we drive back and we'd
all be at school and at work on Monday
so did you grow up speaking Spanish or
something cuz you know you majored in
Spanish as well when we moved so in 94
we move after no 92 so was that for the
hurricane after Andrew we moved back to
Miami okay and then in 95 we moved back
so because my mom cuz we were going to
move to Jamaica from my mother's
clothing business but then my grandpa
got sick so we stayed with my grandpa my
grandpa passed and then my mother was
like [ __ ] it was one night Georgia
swimming but moved back here in 95 and
we've been here ever since
and then I've lived in Pennsylvania
North Carolina for work because I lived
in Pennsylvania I lived in Quakertown
Pennsylvania three months doing summer
stock so summer stock summer stock
theater is um basically every year they
have this thing called the southeastern
theatre conference and you go to the
state theatre conferences to get a
number for setc and then you audition
for professional theatre companies for
you know summer jobs or year-long jobs
if you're about to graduate from college
and so because of you know had me having
technical theater experience to college
and [ __ ] like that I see my junior and
senior of college I was in Quakertown
Pennsylvania for three months we did for
musicals 12 children shows and a
children's camp and then I was a
technician as well
so our day consisted of getting up so we
get up in the morning and then we would
because they they fed us so and we'd
grab breakfast which is usually like you
know uh uh let's just say lost 25 pounds
in three months
water well you know it's like we would
get breakfast and breakfast was like you
know like some fruit I mean you couldn't
have anything too heavy because you're
gonna work all day mm-hmm so I get like
you know like an apple and some peanut
butter and then I'd be in music
rehearsal to lunch
then give us lunch which was like I'm
sick call them foster-home sandwiches
and then you'd have dance rehearsal in
the afternoon or they'd switch it
whichever one we needed to work on and
then so you do music and dance during
the day for one show and then the
evening you'd perform a different show
geez so when we first got there we only
rehearsed barnum which was the first
show we did and then after rehearsals in
the evening we would have children
showed her her slow because every
Saturday was a different children show
so out of the 12 children Shaw was a
nine of them I think in four of them I
was just a bird no lines or anything
just emotive squawking motive squawk I
think we did a Jack and the Beanstalk
how was the Golden Goose and it was just
me going man I was very scared I would
attack to come and get me I was on top
of the staircase like help me but you
know Emotiv squawking mm-hmm so yeah and
then so so yeah so we would do like for
instance like part of the summer it was
like and there was the children's camp
as well so this was insane so like in
the morning we did the music so in the
morning we practiced like the music for
barnum and then the evening no no how
does it seem so random day so how does
succeed music in the morning how to
succeed dance in the in the afternoon
and then you know dinner and then do a
show so we do barnum and then after that
we'd learn the pie
Piper and then after that I would work
on sets and wigs and costumes or
whatever so I probably went to sleep
like a two of the morning and then we
were just up because it was like all of
us because we lived in the theater mmm
so a lot of us live there so some of it
because like if there wasn't enough room
for everybody then other people lives
like off-site and like the board members
houses but like my room like if you
exited stage right my room was right
there like you went through this door
and then it was me and two other girls
in this bedroom and then there was like
bunk beds yeah I had it like it was it
was like a triple there was bunk beds
and there was my bed since I got there
first I got the single bed doesn't know
I'm doing it he's seniority but the rest
of the room where some of the rooms are
bunk beds and some of the rooms were
just like twin beds but they were like I
think like seven rooms upstairs and then
there were like mine like five rooms
downstairs with like me too most of them
were like two people almost three people
and we all live there we all live there
and then so when we started doing the
children's camp it was a music and dance
rehearsal in the morning and then the
children's camp in the afternoon and
then there was a show and then there was
learning the children's and then
learning the next show for the following
for that Saturday and then still wigs
and costumes and sets and [ __ ] all
running on the fuel of foster home
sandwiches always called them lunch was
foster home sandwiches basically you
know blowing and cheese and cheese puffs
mm-hmm until that beautiful day with a
Talia found out that there was a
thousand packs of butter in the freezer
so we had grilled foster homes and you
know kids are coming up and then every
Friday before the show the board members
would like get us dinner usually like
blossom market or something but any
other night the the director of the
theater company cuz he had an apartment
attached to the theater which looked
nothing like where the [ __ ] we lived you
thought it was a completely different
place I'm like is this Narnia what is
this the hell and so he was it was like
a lot of pasta like you know cuz it's
cuz he had to feed 30 people yeah who
had been dancing and singing all day
long but like we but like cuz that
summer I got to go to New York for the
first time cuz we were like 30 minutes
from Philly and we took the Peter Pan
Bus which I had never [ __ ] heard of I
was before mega bus right was for
megabus was the Peter Pan Bus that you
took from like I think Allentown
Pennsylvania to New York and we went and
I was just like this is it this is what
you [ __ ] have been telling me
about my whole life like you weren't
impressed
no oh my god that Disneyland on the
rides were off like teacups [ __ ] yeah so
this is when your mom calls and is like
oh hey dulce by the way I had a dream
that you're supposed to be a famous
comedian that was oh my mother told you
about that or I talked about that oh I
just knew about that I know she talked
too sure about it um Chad to start
seeing [ __ ] [ __ ] you he'll be on here
too
he knows us with love he's in India
right now but um basically I was when I
wasn't working in 2009 cuz I mean uh
twerking happens a lot praise God and I
was doing sketches sketch works and I
did the first class and Big Kenny had
been after me for like two years to
start doing stand-up mm-hmm cuz the
friend of mine worked at the funny farm
and I would go up there just and hang
out so I'm doing [ __ ] and um I'll go
there hang out with her and I just met
big Kenny and then I met Quincy bonds
and you know talk to them or whatever
and just been talking to them they're
like oh you're a comic I'm like no but
after like no you are a comic and I'm
like I'm [ __ ] talking about so I was
like no I'm not doing that like you
should go up on stage is write some
jokes I had no idea - [ __ ] no idea
help do this and stand-up scare the [ __ ]
out of me hmm
because I grew up as an actor so like
any time I was on stage they weren't my
words it wasn't me and it was a
fourth-wall
I didn't have these things sounds like
[ __ ] you this is insane no no and then
two years straight I kept running in the
big king so I would go to like an event
like I went to a fundraising event and
big Katie was there performing with like
doodoo brown or I'd go to another thing
like some Walker and he's there from
think I kept running into him
and I'm like why do I keep running into
you and he's like it's fate you dummy
and I was like Touche mm-hm and lose his
job or whatever so two years later I'm
taking the sketch works class and they
asked me to do the next level of the
class and at the same time be Kenny had
hit me up and it was like I got another
standard class starting up you need to
do it and I'm not kidding and I was
talking my mom about it and she's like
oh I had a dream about you being a comic
she's like I had a dream that you were a
stand-up comedian and you were and you
were performing and I was like all right
sorry I'll take a class I'm fine but it
was like here's the thing it's like if
your mom has a dream about something
you're probably supposed to do it right
exactly just and you know southern
mysticism or black whatever it's just
like me your mom like like my freshman
year college I was [ __ ] around doing
stuff I should've been doing I got was
on drugs but like we were hanging out
places we were you know hanging out with
dudes we should have been hanging out
with we were doing sure we weren't
supposed to be doing I was like 18 year
old girls very [ __ ] like we could end
up on the [ __ ] news
probably once or twice losing all
women's college what was a women's
college but Lake we were still in a town
right and so and look people go up to
asin's and hang out like you know we're
hanging out with dudes we didn't know
about their house but it had a [ __ ]
dangerous and so my mother calls me up
one day and was like whatever you're
doing stop and this is a for self like
before everybody had a cell phone so my
freshman year at college
she's calling a room phone and she's
like whatever you're doing stop it and
I'm like I'm not doing and she's like
don't play with me
whatever you're doing cut it the [ __ ]
out and I was like okay I know my
friends and I was like my mom said shut
it down and they were like what are you
talking about I was like my mother just
called me and say whatever you're doing
stop it and I'm afraid you know and it's
talking to a group of black girls and
they're like okay
yeah oh wow we ain't going up her mama
just called her and told us to quit is
she known about nothing no oh no [ __ ]
that the Lord told her we knew would
[ __ ] up nothing was with other girl she
was like we're going up we were like and
did you stop yeah stop your mother calls
you out of nowhere and tells you to sit
the [ __ ] down that had to be the Lord
going your daughter's in danger tell her
to chill the [ __ ] out and that's exactly
what I did I was like I'm not going
anywhere doing [ __ ] I'm look I go one
who's white girls are going we were
doing some dumb [ __ ] and then sometimes
daily didn't [ __ ] know cuz I got to
go be a bouncer down at Georgia Tech
with these broads a bouncer I was
friends with like I had three groups of
friends in college I had on my black
friends and then I had theater friends
and then I had my sorority friends and
so like they would go down and party at
like Georgia Tech and so we're partying
at frat houses at Georgia Tech and we've
all seen a Lifetime movie um so I spent
a lot of time making sure my friends
didn't end up in Lifetime movie right
because they were it was like they pull
some [ __ ] with them they wouldn't pull
some [ __ ] with me
oh you were like the mother of the group
almost always all ways one of my friends
ended up in a very scary situation which
consisted of me yanking a dude off of
her and throwing him down some stairs
hmm and from then on it was like okay
mama don't say like this is so they're
getting caught mama does in high school
mama don't say in high school Wow and I
never told anybody to call me that
and then again in college and now it's
like the younger comics they call me
that I never tell anybody to call I'm
never gonna call mom a little thing
because I'm why would I do that why
would I tell people like listen I'm 32
can you follow me well that's now gonna
be the title of this episode I'll punch
you in your mouth mama Dulce what's good
genetics because your mom clearly has
good instincts telling you to stop
messing around and to start stand-up
well yeah it almost because like if it
wasn't for like all those meetings like
all the opportunities there I've gotten
and like being able to like sit with
them bc and meet with like the different
networks i've been able to meet with is
because of standeth mm-hmm like I
wouldn't have been able to get in the
room with any of those people if I would
have kept acting when I know that so
where was your first performance outside
of the grad show because you had your
first time performing was the graduation
show of your class right so then where
did you start performing around the city
after that so yeah and then I just went
up like because when I first started I
did any room I can do so like I was
doing urban rooms on mainstream rooms I
was just trying to get up wherever I
could get up so and then it just got to
the point where I was like I was getting
more opportunities to go up in
mainstream rooms so I just was like that
driving all over the [ __ ] city this
is insane I got work in the morning I
could just go to use made like white
rooms and my name is on the list I know
I'm gonna get up so I just stuck with
those rooms and I just dealt with last
[ __ ] in those rooms so that's what I did
I mean that's what I stuck with and
that's what like and I'm glad I did it
because I got the opportunity really
like cuz I still go back and like do
those other shows but it got to the
point where I was getting so many shows
in the mainstream rooms that I was like
yeah a point where nobody would know who
I was in the urban room in the urban
room but a lot of people that do urban
rooms in Atlanta have a story of getting
booed you know do you have one of those
I got a no I've gotten quiet which
you've never gotten booed you can get
out of quiet you can't get out of booth
you never got booted I've not been booed
in the urban room I've gotten quiet an
urban room okay which is even weirder
okay because it's like y'all don't care
is that because the thing is if you're
if you boo then you know you don't like
it if you're quiet then you're just
trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
going on and it's the quiet that's weird
like I'm like if I'm booed cool thank
you you don't like it if you're quiet
I'm like all right well let me try
something else and it's still quiet I'm
like all right [ __ ] crowd work I get
this in their desk but I just have to do
but yeah if you're if
not in boot but I've gotten why do you
think I know you've said growing up you
sometimes felt like you weren't quote
black enough did you feel like that in
the urban rooms as well no I never said
that I didn't feel like I was black
enough other black people would say I
was black oh okay I was as black as I
was going to be because I'm black
sure there's no this is as black as I
can like this is as black as I occur
mm-hm so you know if being black is
being uneducated if being black is being
poor if being black is all of these
negative things that I'm not going to
cosign to that because I know that's not
what being black is it's whatever I am
so you know the idea of not black enough
is something that was invented by other
black people and then taken on by white
people to [ __ ] with me at auditions so
right so it's you know I didn't write I
ran into I would have male comics say to
me ah doesn't st. [ __ ] with you you [ __ ]
with them white boys and I'm like are
you talking about me doing shows you're
talking about actually [ __ ] white
boys what are you saying and it's like
oh you know it was his big titty big
Kenny's only when I started he was like
don't let don't let urban comics
pressure you make you feel bad about not
doing those fruits because you need to
do those rooms meaning don't make me
feel bad about not doing urban rooms
what I'm doing mainstream rooms you know
don't let them make you feel bad
don't let them you know try to pressure
you or [ __ ] with you about the fact that
you're not out there with them when
you're out there working you're just on
doing other rooms and it was funny
because like in like 2012 like every
black comic that I knew almost was like
don't say huh get these white rooms I
getting these white room but I'm like
show up right it is it mm-hmm
it's not a met there's no keypad there's
no what the
holding there's a cheat codes just come
to the show and cuz I never I understand
why there is a divide I get it because
when you go to places like Texas and
when you go to places like Los Angeles
or you know there are Hispanic like
there's Latin rooms there's max there's
flat-out Mexican rooms there's a whole
other circuit of stand-up that we don't
know about because we don't have those
comics here we learn that population
here where they have their own club so
there's a reason that there's division
because we funk because there's a
different what sweating translates like
there's different sensibility because
like you know you know when an urban
room you have to have a laugh every 30
seconds we all know that hmm I've been
in mainstream rooms [ __ ] has a two
minutes set up and you're like this is
unnecessary matter what the [ __ ] room
you're in tell the damn joke mm-hmm
unless they're cause like so when I have
longer bits
I have little jokes in the longer bed so
the crowds not going what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] is pointing like or any time
I see somebody any comic with a long set
up I'm like this punch better make
somebody flip a [ __ ] table this is
too long this is too long why I said why
I got a minute 1/2 not laugh yet what
are you talking about so see even you
were seeing comics that don't do
30-second punchlines and you're like
wolf speed it up well it's if you're not
going to that's what I'm saying if you
are if you have a longer set up a
problem with a longer set up it needs to
be in and even if there's not a laugh in
the setup it needs to be an entertaining
set up I need to be engaged with your
set up because there are some commas I
know they're very funny and they have a
longer set up but I'm engaged if you're
just talking for a minute in the [ __ ]
half and this could have taken 45
seconds then you're just terrorizing the
audience yeah so if you're gonna have a
longer set up it needs just beer to be
engaging I'd entertaining be engaging
with it make me want to hear what the
next thing is so yeah there's different
sensibilities if the things that they
talk about cuz sometimes like I can go
to why
ones and go [ __ ] these white boys
talking about these actually she's just
every [ __ ] white boys I'm exact same
[ __ ] thing
when white boys start staying apart
another [ __ ] I'm talkin about
mm-hmm and it's like but when I go to
urban rooms it's the same thing it's
like everybody's talking about the same
[ __ ] mm-hmm
man it's like no one else what the [ __ ]
you people do like you know how do you
walk in nature why are y'all talkin
about this same thing and like cuz you
sometimes like I said back and looking
like there's so many [ __ ] comics
because I can't was like skull festival
like 400 people I deduce close friends
mm-hmm they took 72 and you're like who
who applied cuz you know I'm not
impressed with the talent and the know
what I'm saying is like that's a lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] like 400 comics mm-hmm cuz
the comics over in the skull festival
were great because there's been other
years of the skull festival when I've
been like just hanging around and being
backstage and there were definitely
comics that didn't want other comics to
do well so they could go to the next
round right this year everybody wanted
everyone to do well so they can feel
that they earned their spot if they
moved on so I was glad of the people
that they had this year because they
were good comics they were nice people
but 405 wherefore ah to comic-con he's
blowing up right now there's a lot of
[ __ ]
yeah you said I'm saying is there's so
many [ __ ] people or comics and you're
like but there's people applying the
festivals of like I've been doing
stand-in for six months I should go to a
festival right so I could talk himself
into throw [ __ ] because when I'm like
Berenbaum was in town the other week he
was talking about this joke he has about
like groups of like animals so easy cuz
we were talking about different poop
Savannah was like Oh crows like a murder
of crows like a pod of dolphins and I
said what's a group of comics and he was
like it's an entitlement a group of
comics as an entitlement of comics and I
almost fell down in the street we were
walking back and
I was like it was exactly right yeah
exactly right when I first started in
life sciences let's stand up six and a
half years ago there were no shows on
Tuesday there were no shows on Thursday
no mainstream rooms on Tuesday and
Thursday there were no shows on the you
could you weren't expected to be at a
club on the weekends
to watch and learn that's just six and a
half years ago and that's six and a half
years ago now there's fully I could do
four shows on a Tuesday yeah but on
Monday still it's still star bar like
star and then they had that you know and
then um Ben Palmer head the room at the
UH at that barn oh no no no okay
um so I've seen stuff chained and then
relax relax amazing yeah and more IP Oh
that basis I was the first time I saw
the Dulce Sloan in the shining light
when you close out the show and like you
just just like the confidence and like
your persona even back then you know
this was probably like this was when I
was hosting the open mic there so I mean
this was maybe like three or four years
ago now maybe and I remember yeah seeing
you and like as soon as you got offstage
and I just closed out this show I was
like I need to talk to you hey what was
that what did you like took me through
your notebook you're like well this is
what I did here and you like that was
the first time we really talked was like
we were just standing there at the bar
not drinking just looking at your
notebook and I was like that was amazing
like your confidence and it seems like I
guess from the theater background is
just that you've never you're not afraid
of silence and like you just you just
can milk it and you just like just roll
in that there's two kinds of silence
there is silence because we're listening
mm-hmm and silence cuz we don't know
what's going on um it's very rare that I
get the that's the one thing that's
happened me like in black rooms it's
like if they are not on board
they just don't say anything wait just
like what the [ __ ] do I do with this
information I thought I'm gonna get
booed at least some type of reaction but
silence is like hmm alright was she
gonna be doing so what [ __ ] but it's but
I had to
learn how to work with silence I had to
learn how to work with my tone because
something like the best thing you can do
sometimes for a rowdy crowd is lower
your voice okay
and I figured that out I was at the
thing I was one of those shows in
McDonough where I just it wasn't at
three months where I quit writing
setlists because I kept getting
interrupted because my style is a
conversational people's like I'm talking
to them so people want to engage me in
conversation and then I've didn't
embarrassed some dad and McDonagh on a
Tuesday night um or wherever we were
doing a show so I had to figure out like
with a loud crowd like a drunk crowd I
would just lower my voice and increase
my intensity and then people would go
what he what did she say what the [ __ ]
and they get quiet because they're
trying to figure out what I'm talking
about
mm-hmm so you're drunk having this
conversation if I'm talking in a regular
volume you'd want it you know oh I could
figure out what you're saying i ha you
know but if I'm too quiet you know you
can't tune me out it is you don't know
what I'm saying
what is she and then I can bring it back
up if I want or I'll just stay at that
level but I had to learn very quickly
cuz like I've done shows that I was
gonna show in college for a 900 seat
house and there's no mics cuz the
theater was over 100 years old yeah and
you have to get your voice to the back
of that room and I was playing a
mountain god and so I'm on a 6 7 8 foot
platform that was like a square that was
5x5 so and I was up there at the
beginning of the show so I stacked this
do children's with only 45 minutes and
so I sat on this platform on this
mountain for 30 minutes and then a co2
thing goes off and then I break open a
mountain and then I stand up and so and
I'm on a mountain and then there's other
set pieces and then an amount
God so I am giving hippo the ability to
swim and I it is further back so I have
to make my presence known in front of
all of this set in front of people
dancing in costume and then a seat of
900 and everyone in the audience is
between kindergarten and fifth grade and
asked to make all of you pay attention
so I had to learn very quickly okay how
do I have the presence to get everyone
in this room to pay attention to me it
helps to pop out of a mountain with co2
canister but I can't tote mountains with
me to show so I learned from theater how
to cuz I own comics are asked when they
first start out like how do I have
presence on the stage and the main thing
I would say to people is plant your feet
quit moving
mm-hmm cuz you see me on stage you
realize I'm gonna so I'm gonna spot and
I don't deviate I find my light and I
stand there because usually your
microphone is in your life I move if I
have to umm there's a lot of comics like
to pull the whole Chris Rock Payson
thing sweetie not everybody's good at
that and you've only been doing stand-up
for three months so you need to [ __ ]
be still because if you're walking back
and forth cuz they the thing about Chris
Rock is set up set up set up punchline
still set up set up set up punch line
still yeah you don't know that he does
that because you just start it be still
be still it's it because if you're gonna
Steve you once you stand in you're like
you stand in your light it's called
finding your leg for a reason
you stand in your light you get the
microphone that's when you create your
presence on the stage because if you see
people when they first sat out the stage
is bigger than them so some people get
swallowed up by a stage but if you can
be still and focus then you'll start to
fill up the stage just by yourself and
that's what begins but that's the main
thing comics have to learn is even if
you're on a [ __ ] pallet at a brewery
you have to not fit that stage is not
your stage the entire wall you're
standing in front of is the stage this
entire brewery is a [ __ ] stage so I
have to be able
fill up this entire brewery I'm not
staying I'm not thinking about this spot
people in the back have to give [ __ ]
drunk brought on the side has to pay
attention so that's the point every time
you get on stage it's not I don't like
when comics say oh I'm a comic cuz I'm
[ __ ] up all of this getting up on
stage doing stream-of-consciousness
bitching about your life where the [ __ ]
is the joke terrorism stop it
I'm dead-ass you know you got an entire
audience full you got a room full of
people in here and other people have to
go up after you and you were selfish
enough to get on [ __ ] stage and whine
about your life and not make it jokes
I'm killing everybody's time killing
everybody's time up if you're going to
[ __ ] about your life at least tell a
[ __ ] joke and that's what's great
about your stand-up is that there are
jokes in there I mean it's hilarious
first I mean people love you my mom I'm
supposed to say my mom says hi yeah and
you you'll like swear during her show
and like she'll like cringe when she
hear swear words but like she's like
when don't say cusses I just I don't it
just warms me I don't know well my
mother says I've been cussing since the
age of five and she says she said to me
air station said you say [ __ ]
the way you did and you were a little
girl like really she said you always hit
that th real hard I was like thank you
mom yeah there's a music to it and also
with your stand-up there is this I don't
have called persona but you can't say
there's like the sassy black woman and
you having a theater background how much
of your standup is you playing that
character see and the problem is that I
don't want to be that character that's
not the person I'm trying to be and
whenever I get auditions or whenever I
do something I have to go is this the
stereotype is this a real human in you
know is this or am I just playing up on
something that you know white people are
afraid of but at the same time it's like
oh this is you know like when I did that
thing for riggles pics and I was like
postmaster Monique or whatever
I'm going through the lines at one point
they're like we need you to be more
sassy as it excuse me
what do you mean and then like we just
need a little bit more sass I'm like
this is fancy as I get how about y'all
relax
and he was like that do that that's
perfect I'm Simon [ __ ] you what we've
been we go we'd had enough takes and
stuff riding you know got a rapport with
them I'm not yelling [ __ ] you two
directors I just met right cuz I want to
work again um cuz it's like and this is
conflicting about that because it's like
oh you don't want to be sassy black
woman you don't want to be this person
but yet I've still seen the lady going
off on somebody in a post office so and
I'm playing a stereotype is she playing
it's like who the what's this who's a
stereotype so because you know there's
sassy black woman there's angry black
woman but me it's just I'm talking to
you with intent I'm telling you that I
care about this so as I remembered like
Joe Galois hi Joe what joke he was like
uh he's like I should call you first
call me I'll ask last massage and I was
like that's hilarious and I remember I
was doing it was like three years ago
and I was doing shows Berenbaum after
skull and we were joking about this and
Baron was like absolutely not no never
do not do that and right over just
joking around he's like [ __ ] no do not
do that he was like because that's what
you're going he said they're always
gonna see you as that don't give that to
them it has to be something stronger
than that it has to tell he that if
you're doing that then you might as well
just be any other you're gonna start any
other black woman into that it has to be
something where people are gonna go oh
she is different or you know oh this is
something that something that's catches
of like something that's like not a
typical thing so I'm always trying to
make sure when I get auditions and stuff
it's like oh I'm black best friend of
course but what kind of black best
friend like I'm either black best friend
it's like yeah white girl you know your
life is so hard
Oh chicken hot sauce like
I'm not or I get my black best friend on
my your friend who's black that's two
different things
mm-hmm cuz it's like you don't want to
extract the fact that you know it's
oh she's you know Scotty you know she's
not a big personality and all this other
[ __ ] but there's a difference between
sassy black woman and girl with big
personality so I try to when I'm on
stage I'm not that's not an you know and
usually why people say that to me and I
used have to go that's not it's not what
I'm doing I am being like these are my
thoughts this is the way that I relate
these thoughts because it's funny cuz
it's like with me doing those college
shows hmm my college agent was like I
love you she's like I love your you know
personality and your intensity with your
jokes
she said just make it a little lighter
just make it a little happier smile more
she said say exactly what you're saying
hmm but just a little less she said I
was like less attitude she's like yes
just bring it up just smile more and
just because like sometimes I'll do my
set I'll drop my tone down I get very
intense and she's like just come up she
said you can still be a little intense
but like intensity as opposed to
intensity like just bring it up and so I
have to be conscious of when I do those
shows and of the audience of okay I
can't I can't scare these kids like
that's something that's what I have to
pay attention to but no sassy black
woman is something that I constantly
fight yeah tea because I I mean you you
know you have the joke about your mom
teaching you the white voice and you'll
go like from sassy to like the white
voice and it's like I've heard you say
you know you don't want to be a
caricature right you know of a black
woman and everything but it's like I've
seen I've seen you be sassy but I've
also seen you have a double quinceanera
where you have a matching American Girl
doll and court full court escort yep so
it's like those two worlds you know I
mean are you trying to find middle
ground I mean I mean it's
all of those things are me like the idea
for the first of all okay I know people
don't know what the [ __ ] you mean by the
dovahkiin 10 year I'm so sorry that was
for my 30th birthday my 30th birthday
like I don't know if anyone knows the
kids and yet is it's difficult to spell
so just type in Keene say to the
Internet it'll tell you it's a big
birthday celebration for when you know a
Latino turns 15 so I had a joke with one
of my mom's friends know one of my
friend's moms that for my 30th birthday
I would have a dome-like in Siena and
she has four sons so she never had a
quinceanera none that stuff for her kids
could have any daughters so and we were
joking about this we came up with his
idea when I was like 24 and like six
years later I heard of my friend like
tell your mom I'm having this party and
she comes she's like don't want to say I
thought you forgot all about me and I
was like no Maria I made sure you came
but um like Plus this was your idea so
but for me that wasn't something that
was ridiculous for me because when you
were at the party mm-hmm you were like
okay my Cuban family's here my Mexican
family's here I'm a black family's here
my white family couldn't make it
yeah so for those are all people that
were supportive of me but the funny
thing is the only people in that room
who were actually related to me where my
mom and my brother my actual
blood-related family that my black
family that's how my mamma's friends and
stuff from Miami that live here now none
of my blood related family was active
thing um this is like my family lives
very far we're not very close was like
the uncle were actually closest to lives
in Las Vegas I got three other uncle's
willing to talk to and then my father
had no siblings so my family is very
small and all my grandparents all of my
grandparents are have passed away so
family is very small and so people bring
you in and so that's what it was for me
is like going okay this is to
acknowledge all the people who have
taken care of me who have brought me and
that's why I did that but and also I
thought it was hilarious
yes I haven't come up with this original
idea nope some [ __ ] had already done it
but she didn't do it like I did it all
she had was like a [ __ ] party in her
backyard with like the margaritas and
[ __ ]
Bishop handle dresses she didn't have
Dhamma she didn't have some blaze I
worked the [ __ ] out there's a roast
there was a roast um which was funny cuz
some of people in the Rose feel like we
really wanted our own shoe but we didn't
want you to get mad at us and I was like
it's a [ __ ] roast right yeah so cuz
people still talk about you and Joe
Galois on that roast but um I don't
think those are different I don't think
those are different things cause like I
grew up with a lot of like my neighbor's
growing up in one network mostly
Hispanic mostly Latino mostly Mexican
and so I was always on my neighbor's
house cuz like I look what I learned
Spanish when we move honey Osmonds
earlier when we moved to Miami in 92 I
was like in the fourth grade and in
Miami you learnt like you don't have
like art music and PE you know I'm in
tree school you take Spanish as well
every single day and so every single day
for fourth and fifth and half a sixth
grade I took Spanish and I wanted to
learn it so I was always like I gotta
get as much as a speck possibly get to
the point like in the fifth grade I was
like I would translate documents from my
teacher who's her name Senora mayorga
haha but she would get stuff like
paperwork like teacher [ __ ] and her
teacher box from the school and she'd be
like total thing come here and she's
like what's this thing and so I have to
translate into Spanish so I was like oh
well they want you to do this you have
to do this this is this and this is some
other [ __ ] like I was you know some
words I didn't know but I'd give her the
gist of it and then that's what I did
when I got we moved into Norcross on the
seventh grade like I said register my
name was kids for school which I did not
know what a 14-year old you could
register no children for school
mama Dulce apparently I registered my
neighbor's kids for school
one of my neighbors had to get health
insurance from her job she was working
as a housekeeper at a hotel
so I came home from you know the
colleges at this point and I went with
her to her job and helped her register
for her health insurance her name her
husband got a DUI and that explains
legally [ __ ] to her and like a hands-on
learning right like hands-on like
telling them what's going on and then
just from growing up with all of my lot
of my friends were hit like flattened
you know especially like in high school
than because you know if you know
Spanish look I think there's so many
people my high school [ __ ] like
everybody [ __ ] high school no Spanish
blacks why there's a verse I use a very
diverse high school and so like our
teachers knew if they were getting
cussed out in 12 different languages
dad serious mm-hmm like you just like
opens if you don't you know put that to
your teacher now she knows what you're
saying but like our teachers knew if
they were getting called a [ __ ] in
Spanish Portuguese Chinese Japanese
Korean Vietnamese Romanian Russian
German like our teachers had to [ __ ]
know listen I know the [ __ ] you just
that but it sounded wrong but yeah cuz
some kid said like call our teacher
[ __ ] like Romanian she was like oh you
don't think I know what that means
come here and you got written up for
calling her [ __ ] in Romania well all
these people that are close to you and
all these different cultures that know
you personally when they see your stand
up do they see the sassy black woman or
do they see Dulce they see me okay and
only harp on it because I've heard you
like battled this before and like no I'm
not the sassy black woman but then it
like it seems like you are playing this
character in that mm-hmm you seems like
you lean into that stuff a lot I think
it's sometimes I do it if it's I don't
always [ __ ] like I think that's a
character for people who are outside my
culture um cuz I got a friend in college
who I was on the phone with my mom one
day and she was just laughing I was like
what's up you laughing about she's like
you've been on the phone with your mom
for 30 minutes a lot of partners mm-hmm
but I'm talking about but like I'm
because if you're just quiet konchol
dropped so to say something to let her
know that I'm still on the phone but if
I'm hanging I was one of my black
friends and I hear her on the phone with
her mom or whoever she's gonna I know
like mm-hmm
okay she's talking to somebody black so
it's I only get called sassy by white
people okay I don't get called sassy by
black people I don't get called angry
black woman by black people
I've been called angry by black people
when I was [ __ ] mad but like that's
the one part of black women that white
people white men can understand oh
they're so sassy and funny better like
that's the part that white people get it
sounds like casting agents seem to put
you in that small space as well they put
every black like that's why you have
movies like bamboozled that's why you
have the characters written on TV that
you have like I did a but then I'm now
in this weird Nam in this weird place
because it's like I've read for a pilot
and the casting director cuz I've
already sent in a tape in for it before
they liked my tape and they're like oh
we're doing live casting so coming you
know coming to read and the casting
director happened to see me on the NBC
showcase she knows on it she was like I
saw your tape it seemed like you were
acting of course I was [ __ ] acting
mm-hm it's a tape and she said I'd like
to tape it seemed like you were acting I
just want you to be yourself and I was
like okay but a my brain I'm like how
the [ __ ] do I do day how do I do that
like that goes against 12 years of
acting training she was literally like
say these lines she's like you know I
liked how she's like I liked the
personality that I saw on stage and I
was like okay cool that's me
mm-hmm cuz I tell my joke something
because the thing is it's like when I'm
on stage as a performance I'm putting on
a show even the best comic has to turn
your you can't perform constantly yeah
that heightened sense that being aware
of every that being in control of the
room you can't be that person all of the
time but that's what casting agents
expect you to do as well and that's and
so I have to realize that the person
that I am when I'm onstage is not that
it's not me it's not like it's a Larry
the Cable Guy situation where this is a
totally different you know
that's me but that is me being able to
say what I want us what I'm being able
to say what I'm thinking and what I want
to say and the way that I want to say it
because I could totally just be as nice
and sweet and say those jokes because
I've done it
or I could be really low-key with those
jokes because I've done that or I can be
completely over-the-top because I'm
gonna [ __ ] showcase Jim saying like
when you like we jus saw me on that
showcase I was in [ __ ] battle mode
right like the goal is to make sure that
no one else in this [ __ ] wins
but me so it is going to be too much
it's going to it's going to be over the
top it's still me
much I'm not you know rolling my neck or
whatever because that's why I say in
that joke I'm trying to get a white dude
there's like no no no I'm one of the
nice ones mm-hmm like I don't be don't
be scared okay come on like look my neck
doesn't even move when I talk
come on Kevin so in the middle of that
joke I'm talking about that these are
the stereotypes that they have for us
mm-hmm white man calm down I'm not one
of the like you see what I'm saying
but the fact that and like some people
only black people catch that I say that
in that Chuck people white people catch
them down saying I'm one of the nice
ones some of them do some of them catch
it and don't want it laughs black people
always [ __ ] laugh and only certain
white people catch you know I'm one and
I suppose my neck doesn't even move when
I talk black people always catch that
white people occasionally and the ones
that catch you don't want to last so
it's I still have to put sure cuz it's
like I have to make sure that I'm not
what they say that I am but of to
realize that that person is a that
person's a person like this sassy black
girl going off papadum then it I've seen
that I've seen that chick so what do I
do get that chick to go to [ __ ]
college so I get better casting to sit
like that's that's too much I have to
like I have not fixed
I could change the entire the way every
single black woman
so I can get better casting calls that's
insane but you have to realize okay
is she the stereotype I the stereotype
are you [ __ ] for writing this this
way who's wrong but a lot of time gonna
get stuff I'm like we don't talk this
way
don't act like this I don't know what
you thought it this is unrealistic no
black person acts that way but and you
know you're like okay well then who how
would you do it like I do it like I do
it that's good to have that confidence
so early on in navigating this world
because that's kind of a new step in
your career you can get it on stage but
now you have to figure out you know that
whole network and how to act and I know
someone you learned a lot from Holly
about Hollywood from was like Margaret
Cho oh I've talked to her a few times
like I we've met a little bit I'm doing
this be Robin show that she's doing it's
a benefit show for the homeless she put
she started doing after Rhonda Williams
passed away because you know she
considers him one of her comedy fathers
like he took care of her just like Joan
Rivers one of her comedy mothers and
I've always looked up to her and you
know just from knowing her history and
just a few times that I've talked to her
and met her and knowing what she went
through in the industry as an Asian
woman as an Asian woman as a woman who
didn't fit the you know blonde blue-eyed
you know slim a stereotype it's you're
always like and as a woman you're
fighting and as a black woman you're
fighting and you're like this is
exhausting so I just have to make sure
okay what is my fight what is my fight
to make sure that everything that I'm in
that I'm not the sassy black woman to
know that as a woman who's not a size
six that I can be portrayed as sexy on
something that I can be seen as an
object of attraction as an object of
affection to know that just because I'm
not thin doesn't mean I don't deserve
love like that is one of the reasons
that I do that broad robe so is that
your overall goal is to really because I
mean you you clearly have high
expectations for yourself as you should
right as you completely
should I mean you're extremely talented
and you achieved so much in such a short
comedy career
so is your goal overall as Dulce Sloane
like are you looking to like break a
mold and really blazed a trail for women
to follow you
I just want me to be okay but there's
someone more I look up to and then when
I listen you know because I saw Margaret
in Montreal and you know there is
activism in her set right and that's
something because like I feel like I'm
not that much of an activist but I'm
still trying to show people I'm a whole
person so you can see like oh you know
she's funny just I thought her hair but
a lot of my jokes are look at what
you're doing to me you're putting your
hands in my hair you are saying
fucked-up stuff to me like look at like
we'll listen to what I'm saying this is
what you're doing like men you're
telling me I'm too fat to date you are
yelling at me from across the street
you are too afraid to talk to me for
whatever [ __ ] reason because society
told you you're supposed to be sounds
like some activism is Sloane I mean it's
just like um but I'll have any jokes
about this so it's like that's why they
joke about film is like I don't [ __ ]
get it like y'all want equal pay for
equal work that is totally accurate but
I don't want to [ __ ] work like this
like stand-up in all of this I do this
because I love this but I know I have to
make sure this [ __ ] stays on point so I
can pay all of my bills but if I can
find some nice man who will pay for all
of this [ __ ] I'm totally [ __ ] fine
with that I have no problem being a
trophy right the only thing is I talk
too much
you clearly have you know more than just
alright if somebody will pay for this I
mean you have stars tattooed on your
body you're not aiming for the middle
here no not even [ __ ] yeah I've started
on my body you know
and your mom dreamed you were a star
right and
she calls me this is why I have these
because my mom calls me star like I have
these things because this is my nickname
that strong my foot is a star that's
broken in half and one side is comedy
one side charge me I know who I am
another lane that I'm running I know I'm
gonna have to work for my money I know
that I've known since I was a child that
I was going to have to work I knew that
me being evident me being able to do
what I want to do is a blessing me
having to sit in someone's day job
wasn't means to in it mm-hmm I could
have got married at 22 and I had to
[ __ ] work and still had to do this my
career completely different directory
but I would also have a different
mindset and what I have to do because on
top of still doing stand-up and then I'm
still doing and then them you know I'm
trying to keep doing sketch but I've
gotten really busy but also jewelry
business you know I just did a kid's
birthday party to me like a month ago so
there's other things that I do because I
need all of these things to be me so in
the same thing where you were saying
like you know there's this part of you
and then there's this part of you all of
those things are me no one knows I'm a
giant [ __ ] nerd no one has any idea
that my dream role in a movie is to be a
Cleon in the Star Trek no one knows that
they do now
thank you I you know as did yesterday I
watched craft in America on PBS and then
I made [ __ ] and your jewelry business is
called star jewelry right yeah I called
Australia it's it's means star in
Spanish but it's spelled on my brother
spelled on the spelled phonetically my
mother calls me that is the name of my
you know it's the name of my business
you know have a production company a
proper call that you but when you have a
production company I would have some
production time boom cuz I'm gonna have
to do stuff because there's so many
people like the thing is is not like 30
years ago where all you had was the
network's and then cable you know
Netflix is doing original program Hulu
and Amazon are doing original
programming people have [ __ ] YouTube
towns doing original stuff so it doesn't
cuz you know you might okay I got a
pilot in stock Dipper then I picking it
up because for whatever reason or you
know things aren't going the way you
wanted to go just be like [ __ ] it I'll
do it come to me with it and I'll put it
on whatever the [ __ ] I need to do it
with but I also need to be able to have
my money make money so I still gotta
have my mother's always about different
revenue streams it's like my mother's
like okay let's do
with makeup or let's do this for this or
let's do this or you know we've got the
jewelry well as well did you do this why
don't you do this why don't you do
makeup why don't you do this because
it's all about you gotta have multiple
revenue streams hmm and tone Bell talked
about on on hot breath this show that I
he had a check for like a hundred fifty
thousand that when it finally trickled
down to him he had 19,000 Wow yeah sir
by tuned into that episode that's posted
up right now so I like I like your
approach is that you want you want to be
the power yeah you want in that like a
surely you want to be paving a paving a
path for people you want to be the
vehicle for people to you know be their
own stars even when I was had a day job
I was doing a play and doing stamped
like the play ran Thursday through
Sunday I did shows Monday through
Wednesday mm-hmm and then did the play
and then still had work during the
weekdays so I can do that and still be
like well [ __ ] I need to do something
for my jewelry business but [ __ ] I need
to do this or I need to do this and I
never feel like I'm doing enough stuff
that's that panic from comics like [ __ ]
you got heat I got to do this right now
to do this right now just right now and
then I have my manager going it's not
like [ __ ] takes a while like there's
this one project I'm going back and
forth with these people since July it's
December and it's still not solidified
yet you see what I'm saying so and some
people they hit in and they fizzle out
and you have to make sure like tone one
in 2011 yeah he has a show now that he's
starring on it's 2015
that was four years mm-hmm but tone is
made sure that he stays on top of it
stays relevant because there was two
other shows before this show that he did
with NBC so you can't be afraid of
silence and that's what it always is you
can't be afraid of silence can't be
afraid that your phone's not ringing
this is work like people you know if I
can talk about comics like pager not
like you know I'm a comic because I'm
[ __ ] up no stop
you're [ __ ] comment cuz you want it
because you're a performer and you chose
comedy I'm a performer and I do stand-up
I'm an actor I do improv I do sketch I'm
a performer
it didn't singing and modeling is like
singing it you know because most of the
plays I've been and have been musicals
mm-hmm so and I've done some lifestyle
modeling you know you know of the kid
and uh what cuz ever like I didn't start
saying you know you were [ __ ] up you
know shook you need to work I don't know
I understand her because somebody told
me I was a [ __ ] comic and then kept
popping up in my life mm-hmm and then
pulled me into a class I'm a mother and
a [ __ ] dream about it and so now I
have to do this and big Kenny told me he
said you'll get all that stuff that you
want to get when you start doing
stand-up you'll become a better comic
when you start talking about yourself
hmm
because I had a like there was a point
where like I was like in I was doing it
for like I think I was like a year and a
half in and I was just doing the stuff
that you know really observational [ __ ]
mm-hmm and be can he kept telling me if
you talk about yourself how you feel
about stuff stuff that has happened to
you you're going you're going to have a
break and it is all going to start
happening you time out you know guys
talking you in the grocery store and
stuff right now but you're moving in the
direction of like okay there's social
issues going on here they don't
understand and you come out Margaret Cho
being that same way of speaking on
activism and things right are you going
to do you've been doing calming listen
seven years right so you're still
figuring out I'm so so much you know my
voice you wanna turn right and it's like
but like comics were like oh I got like
you write like comics that write every
day I don't get I don't but I understand
the whole stream of consciousness I get
it but I'm like you got a new job the
pops up every I get him when they come
or when something happens or something
that are cut like you know I was doing
this thing for a little bit about Suge
Knight and how I love him and I'm so
upset these things are happening I love
sugar
mm-hmm these things say many G's left
well I love you baby
and I appreciate you being on here I'm
but before before we adjourn is there
anything else you want the world to know
I'm nice I want a husband I want kids I
want everybody who be okay I want my mom
to be fine I want everybody I know to be
alright and I want people to get
opportunities because they're good not
because their dad is somebody or they
got there or they've had these
opportunities or whatever I want people
to be seen because they're good I got to
make sure that what I do is okay I'm
okay with it everything that come every
product that I produce everything that I
put out I'm okay with it because it's
like you're just starting point you're
not responsible for you anymore because
the problem is when white people are
actors are actors black people actors
they were responsible for every [ __ ]
black person on the planet I come from
Atlanta there's a list of [ __ ]
that I'm going to forget well don't
forget about me you didn't do anything
for me to [ __ ] forget about you
awesome you've always been helpful
you've always been encouraging for me
you've always wanted you know if I
needed some time they need to get on a
show to work for something you've always
been helpful to me always been
supportive of me but those people did
you forget are the people who weren't
supportive because if they weren't
supportive when you first started how do
poor how can you trust how supportive
they will be when you quote unquote make
it well let's support us know where they
can find you and keep up with you as far
as social media website every every
everything is its dual site Sloan comm I
have a fan page on Facebook Instagram
Dulce Sloan Twitter Dulce Sloan all of
the things Dulce Sloan duf CES elevated
yeah so I I didn't get to off track or
sound - no no this is this is a big
pivot in your career and that's why I
want you on here right now is because
you've put in a lot of hard work
is starting to pay off and you're only
gonna climb from here I mean you know
the first time I saw I perform I knew
you know there was something special
going on so I look forward to seeing you
continue to get what you've earned
thank you gracias I'm like girls like oh
you're like wish it because they're like
three Latin people on the showcase
like so where's your family from in
Miami like so what do you like I'm like
I'm black like no one speaks Spanish me
[Music]
Oh your mom had a friend my mother had a
friend in high school named Dulce with
Cuban girl okay and she liked the name
so she's like I gave it to you cuz I
liked it um but I was gonna change my
last name it's our her last name
when I turned like 21 and her last name
is Hill and talk to somebody about it
they're like what's your last name
they're like I was like Sloane they're
like just flows better like don't say
Sloane don't see him say all right
because it works and it flows better so
now we know now we know I almost change
my name and the name I have now is not
my name
but look when I was born my middle my
first name of a middle name was switched
and then my mother like two hours later
I switched it back but this is like when
they like did birth certificates with a
typewriter
so my all the car downstairs she's like
now I'm flipping it and they're like
okay and then they trudge upstairs with
a typewriter and I'm like okay what is
it now cuz she changed like three times
and I'm like listen this is her name
like [ __ ] what is it and they typed it
up again G alright so the name in the
sidewalk will be Dulce Sloane yes and if
I get my accent marks back would be left
it'll be amazing I'm amazing if I
just get my accent more crunchy I
believe you will it's well earned and
deserve thank you so much for your time
don't say salami
thank you totally just it was a catchy
name so people won't forget
[Music]